la fête de l'UMA fête ses 80 ans 600000
personnes sont attendu ce weekend à la
cour-neuve en scène Saint-Denis une fête
où où sont programmé une cinquantaine de
concerts avec notamment Alain Souchon
Jacques Dutron s Sévérino mais la fête
de l'UMA c'est aussi une tribune
politique est attendu notamment Jean-Luc
Mélenchon ses ambitions présidentielles
vont-elles convenir à Pierre Laurent au
commande désormais du Parti communiste
Patricia Issa Marc Savino
depuis qu'il a tourné le dos au Parti
socialiste plus rien ne l'arrête
Jean-Luc Mélenchon poursuit son rêve
être candidat en 2012 mais son parti de
gauche ne peut le porter jusqu'à la
présidentielle alors il s'est allié au
communiste de cette alliance et né le
Front de gauche avec à la clé un score
honorable au dernière régional
6% des années qu'on est dans les mêmes
meetingson a des mots d'ord très voisin
et nous avec les communistes plus on
dépose des propositions de loi au
Parlement sur je ne sais combien de
sujets donc en réalité nous sommes très
voisins effectivement sur le fond ils ne
sont pas si différents un programme
commun doit d'ailleurs voir le jour mais
la présidentielle aiguise les appétits
et Jean-Luc Mélenchon se montre
gourmand l'ambition d'y arriver ça ou si
j'en ai une c'est plutôt celle-là c'est
de me dire on aura refondé une grande
force politique dans ce pays et la
droite a qu'à bien se tenir
parce que c'est eux chaque matin se
diront si ces gensl arrivent au pouvoir
ils vont nous faire les poches et ils
n'ont pas
tort il se voit déjà comme le candidat
du Front de gauche mais chez les
communistes cette idée ne réjouit pas
tous les camarades certains craignent la
main mise de Mélenchon sur le parti
personne n'avalera le Parti communiste
le Parti communiste ne se diluera pas
mais le Parti communiste d'aujourd'hui
c'est un parti qui comme dans les grands
moments de son histoire et nous sommes
dans un moment
l'histoire avec la crise actuelle c'est
un parti qui sait mettre l'exigence de
l'unité au cœur de ses valeurs
aujourd'hui l'unité est affichée mais
elle pourrait bien voler en éclat car il
leur reste à se mettre d'accord sur le
nom du candidat du Front de Gauche au
printemps 2011